les organisations terroristes impliquées
sont des branches du régime d'Ayatollah
en Iran qui encouragent de manière
proactive les activités terroristes en
Israël et contre des cibles israéliennes
et juives dans le monde entier le Hamas
n'aurait pas été en mesure de mener
cette attaque meurtrière sans le
financement le soutien logistique et les
armes qu'il a reçu de l'Iran de l'Iran
la République islamique d'Iran porte la
responsabilité directe des capacités du
Hamas et par conséquent la ilité de de
l'utilisation que le Hamas a faite de
ses moyens il va de soi également pour
le Hizbollah qui constitue le bras long
du régime iranien au Liban qui a annoncé
être responsable de plus que 10 attaques
perpétuées à l'encontre d'Israël ces
derniers jours y compris de tir de
missile antichar de mortiers ainsi que
des tentatives d'infiltration terroriste
ces initiatives sont menées sous la
tutelle et le soutien de l'Iran et
mettent en danger le Liban et ses
habitants